elle a annoncé à travers une interview
donnée à nos confrères du figaro valérie
pécresse est candidate à la présidence
de la république
une candidature focaliser sur une
volonté restaurer la fierté française
je ne supporte plus qu'on parle au lieu
d'agir nous devons rompre avec dix ans
de mauvais choix de demi-mesure
d'indécision et en fin de compte
l'affaissement de notre pays je veux
faire plutôt que de chercher à plaire à
la tête de son mouvement baptisé libre
depuis son départ des républicains en
juin 2019
la présidente du conseil régional d'île
de france venait de lancer un second
mandat à la tête de la région
francilienne
après avoir obtenu près de 46% des
suffrages au second tour des élections
régionales largement devant l'union de
la gauche à plus de 33 % lors du conseil
d'installation elle parlait déjà de sa
vision de la france j'appelle à une
france nouvelle irrigué par ces
territoires oxygénée par ces provinces
une france vraiment décentralisée libéré
une france où l'état assurerait
puissamment ses responsabilités
régaliennes car la sécurité pardon de le
dire c'est une tautologie c'est d'abord
l'état et où ils déléguerait aux
communes départements et régions le soin
de faire vivre la france près de chez
soi une certaine vision de ce qui
pourrait être l'esprit de son programme
à 54 ans valérie pécresse est à la tête
de l'exécutif régional depuis 2015 suite
à sa victoire aux régionales elle
démissionne de son siège de député de la
2e circonscription des yvelines en 2016
un mandat exercé depuis 2002 durant le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy elle a
occupé plusieurs fonctions
gouvernementales
d'abord ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur en portant la réforme de
l'autonomie des universités puis
ministre du budget et porte-parole du
gouvernement
l'autonomie c'est plus de liberté pour
les universités de faire des innovations
pédagogiques
nouer des partenariats y compris avec
les entreprises pour la réussite des
élèves
mais c'est surtout une culture du
résultat et de la performance
nous financerons les universités
autonomes en fonction de la réussite de
leurs élèves en fonction de leurs
débouchés professionnels avec un
parcours politique locale et nationale
elle veut devenir la première femme
présidente de la république en passant
par la primaire je me présenterai en
femme libre
mais nous avons un devoir d'unité de
jouer collectif car il faut un seul
candidat de l'alliance de la droite et
du centre pour l'alternance je n'ai pas
peur de la primaire je ferai tout pour
gagner et rassembler pour le moment
valérie pécresse est la seule candidate
officiellement déclarée à ces primaires
de son côté xavier bertrand a annoncé ne
pas vouloir y participer